un giro de 180 grados de forma
sorpresiva el gobierno de nicaragua
rompió relaciones diplomáticas con
taiwán uno de sus principales donantes
extranjeros y con quién hablar dio años
de buenas relaciones y cooperación
bilateral el gobierno de la república de
nicaragua
declara que reconoce que en el mundo
sólo existe una sola china' la república
popular
chila es el único gobierno legítimo que
representa a toda china y taiwán es
parte inalienable del territorio chino
según datos oficiales tan solo en 2020
taiwán donó 28 millones de dólares al
sector público nicaragüense
hasta ahora el país centroamericano era
uno de los 17 países del mundo que
reconocían a taiwán que es considerado
por china una provincia rebelde desde
mediados del siglo pasado el gobierno de
la república de nicaragua
rompe a partir de hoy las relaciones
diplomáticas con taiwán
y deja de tener cualquier contacto o
relación oficial
pero minutos después del anuncio de
managua la televisión china difundió
imágenes de una delegación nicaragüense
liderada por dos hijos de daniel ortega
reunidos con autoridades chinas en una
ciudad cercana a beijing taiwán era
además un importante socio comercial en
los últimos meses las exportaciones de
nicaragua taiwán representaron más de 60
millones de dólares y unos 25 millones
en importaciones
taiwán lamentó la ruptura de relaciones
diplomáticas con nicaragua y catalogó
como un desprecio a los años de amistad
el gobierno de daniel ortega restablece
las relaciones con china cuando está
aislado por la comunidad internacional y
distanciado de la organización de
estados americanos oea que le exige la
liberación de más de 150 presos
políticos y cuestiona las últimas
elecciones presidenciales
nicaragua se suma ahora a países de la
región como panamá y el salvador que
rompieron con taiwán para alinearse con
la cooperación china